bonjour j'ai un scoop
nous sommes tous devenus des médias nous
sommes tout le temps en train d'émettre
de l'information de recevoir de
l'information
pensez par exemple quand vous voulez
faire une recette de cuisine vous allez
sur internet vous regardez un tutoriel
vous faites votre recette
vous rajoutez une astuce où vous êtes
donc devenu médias un média culinaire
alors les recettes de cuisine c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus commun fait parmi les
sites les plus courus mais il y a à
toutes autres sortes de façons que nous
avons deux nous connecter et d'être tout
le temps connecté
par exemple nous en sommes maintenant à
11 heures de connexions par jour
c'est plus que le sommeil c'est même
plus que le travail
nos jeunes sont 1800 heures devant les
écrans 800 heures devant les enseignants
et 54 heures devant leurs parents et
parents cet attrait médias lorsque nous
sommes en train de nous connecter nous
pouvons regarder jusqu'à deux millions
sept cent quatre-vingt mille vision sur
youtube
nous pouvons faire plus de 2 millions
400 mille recherche sur google donc les
médias nous entoure et forme une culture
c'est très important et moi c'est ce qui
est l'objet de ma recherche en tant que
sociologue des médias
je m'intéresse à aux émotions aux
échanges aux besoins que nous avons de
créer des récits pour nous informer pour
faire du lien même quand il n'y a pas
d'actualité
vous avez remarqué le nombre de photos
de chats mignons à croquer sur instagram
ou sur pinto reste même quand y'a pas
d'infos nous avons besoin de communiquer
et de faire du lien
donc notre rapport à l'information notre
rapport à la culture est quelque chose
d'essentiel et c'est comme en cuisine
quand il ya un élément toxique eh bien
nous avons un empoisonnement plus ou
moins graves mais que se passe-t-il
quand nous sommes face à l'intox dans
des sujets d'importance comme
l'actualité comme la la politique comme
l'économie donc nous avons un besoin
d'échanger et nous sommes poussés de
plus en plus vers de l'information les
jeunes en ce moment ils sont exposés un
à autant de l'information que nous en
avons lorsque nous nous retrouvons avec
youtube avec facebook et cetera donc il
ya un élément de survie qui est
nécessaire c'est presque deux ans
représentent presque besoin d'un manuel
de survie en milieu menteur qu'elle est
l'antidote quel est le contrepoison et
bien pour moi il s'agit d'aller vers une
analyse de tout cela
face à cette abondance d'informations
l'école est en carence c'est byzance
c'est pas byzance justement l'école de
nos jours
ne laisse pas rentrer les médias à
l'école ou très peu en france comme
ailleurs d'ailleurs l'école de 1871
n'est pas prête à affronter les réalités
de 2016
dans certains cas il n'y a pas de
connexion wifi dans d'autres cas il n'y
a pas de d'usagé réseaux sociaux
certains enseignants interdisent de
citer la wikipedia etc
et pourtant et pourtant l'école c'est le
lieu où on apprend le récit on apprend à
se raconter
dès la plus tendre enfance c'est aussi
le lieu de l'inclusion fait le lieu où
l'on peut justement se former aux
cultures de l'information et nous
n'avons pas tous le même capital
médiatique au départ et les enjeux sont
cruciaux la politique poste actuel la
radicalisation
le populisme le complotisme les rumeurs
tous ses enjeux ses tendances 1 sont
lourdes et elles vont rester et nous
avons donc besoin de créer du lien entre
les médias et l'école
certes depuis 2013 la loi de refondation
de l'école a inscrit l'éducation aux
médias qu'on appelle le emmy
dans les textes est certes les
événements de charlie hebdo ont donné à
lui émis une très grande légitimité mais
mais quand on forme les enseignants au
rythme de 20 mille par an nous serons
donc en 2000 96 quand tout le corps
professoral français sera formé aux
médias de 2016
voilà il ya une petite urgence en la
demeure mais il ya d'espoir parce que
l'urgence nous l'avons tous identifiés
et l'urgence c'est de former le corps
des enseignants au plus vite de fournir
aux enseignants les outils
indispensables à ce nécessaire travail
d'éducation aux médias à l'information
moi c'est ce en quoi je crois et c'est
ce que j'essaye de faire dans mes
travaux 1 puisque aider les enseignants
à identifier les ressources à produire
des ressources à échanger à évaluer fait
partie de ce dans quoi je me suis
investi depuis une bonne dizaine une
bonne quinzaine d'années et c'est cette
aide aux enseignants qui me semble être
le plus beau défi en ce moment de
l'école alors comment je le fais je le
fais à la sorbonne nouvelle où
j'enseigne et où j'ai créé un look qui
est un bouc qui permet d'apprendre à
faire de l'éducation un média soi même
on l'appelle le mook le court
massivement ouvert en ligne le mook dit
awa yeux et me dit hawaï pour doux et
user d'un c'est à dire faites le vous
même
l'idée c'est d'inciter le plus en plus
d'enseignants à partager des expériences
et à s'apprendre les uns les autres pour
monter en puissance
il ne pas attendre de 1096 alors comment
on fait eh bien on
présente les enseignants face à des
situations face à des sujets face à des
propositions dans lesquelles ils doivent
développer l'esprit critique et moi je
leur propose lafleur 17 c'est dans
lesquelles vous voyez les trois qui sont
détachés compréhension critique
créativité ce sont les plus faciles à
mettre en place à l'école même quand on
est très peu formés parce que on peut
apprendre très vite un comprendre ce que
c'est que le continent bleu des médias
numériques
c'est à dire les plateformes les moteurs
de recherche etc
on peut très vite aller vers le
continent noir celui justement des
tendances lourdes de la surveillance de
l'activisme de du terrorisme de la
radicalisation et contre balancer
dieu merci avec le continent des
libertés le continent orange le
continent du libre et dans lequel vous
voyez il ya beaucoup du vestiaire tiens
un chat et cette incompréhension et qui
déjà déclenché l'envié de continuer et
de savoir après comprendre ces critiques
et critiquer c'est quel est l'agenda
justement de ces différents moteurs de
ces différents acteurs
qu'est ce qui les pousse à mettre des
fosses des fausses nouvelles qu'est ce
qui les pousse au contraire à faire de
des documentaires très intéressant et
ses terrains tout cela permet de nous
amener vers de l'esprit critique et
notamment d'éviter d'être piégé dans les
mêmes informations encore et toujours
qu'elle soit vrai et que sa fausse ce
qu'on appelle la bulle de filtres la
dernière c'est critiquer et s'est créé
au bout de craie et il y a la
possibilité de ceux publiés et donc
d'être présent en ligne et de produire
des projets qui entraîne l'action et
notamment l'action vers d'autres comme
par exemple la création de feuille de
route que l'on peut partager avec
d'autres collègues avec d'autres
apprenant par exemple ce cas de citoyen
journaliste sur twitter développé par
par des collègues qui ont participé à ce
mook donc c'est ça qui fait l'espèce
deux premiers lyon qui entraîne vers
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information et je mets toujours dans
les moules les enseignants comme les
élèves en posture critique 3 posture
critique essentielle explorateurs
analystes et créateurs c'est à dire
explorateurs c'est pour pour analyser
nous pour balancer pour ces pour
connaître analystes c'est pour critiquer
et créateurs l'avez deviné c'est pour
créer
voilà et au bout de ce processus les
autres éléments les autres compétences
viennent ensemble et elle crée une fleur
la citoyenneté la consommation la
communication interculturelle le conflit
et sa résolution
et c'est avec cela en vain que l'on
arrive à avancer et sur des projets par
exemple le projet avec folique est un
projet avec chypre le portugal la
palestine le maroc où des jeunes
discutent entre eux de conflits et les
surmonte par la création
de l'image numérisée de leur héritage
culturel et donc c'est au bout de ce
processus vous voyez qu'ils ont un avant
et un après avant ils ne comprenaient
pas certaines choses
ensuite ils ont compris maintenant on ne
regarde autrement et c'est avant après
ce changement de comportement et
d'attitude qui pour moi créé
l'importance de l'om où il découvre des
valeurs il découvre de manière très
concrète des choses très abstraite comme
la paix comme la participation comme la
liberté de conscience que la liberté
d'expression est pour moi le et demi
c'est ce qui permet de créer cette
citoyenneté à la fois créative et
critique qui permet de donner sens à des
valeurs universelles
nous essayons tous de partager le émis
pour moi permet d'apprendre à devenir et
pour moi le savoir devenir qui est un
pilier de l'éducation dans le numérique
c'est ce qui permet aux jeunes de
continuer à se mettre à jour tout le
temps ce qui permet de réorienter ses
choix ci permet de faire des erreurs et
de les modifier sans risque
c'est ce qui permet de se faire des
feuilles de route et d'aller jusqu'au
bout des projets et au final eh bien on
obtient la confiance en soi et on
obtient lé estime de soi et c'est
seulement quand on a ce centre mans
important en soi même que l'on peut
aller vers les autres que l'on peut
aller vers la cité que l'on peut aller
vers la démocratie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]